il y à un peu plus d'un an dans cet
immeuble à condos de griffin talent un
copropriétaire a eu une mauvaise
surprise alors qu'il faisait la
vaisselle
le lavabo a cédé la colle de peau tenue
et tulou qu'il contenait s'est répandue
par terre est ce à cause d'un sinistre
alors on a dû faire appel à des
expériences et nice pour nettoyer le
tout faire à sécher les parties enlever
les planches et refaire les moulures le
dégât d'eau en dommages uniquement
unités en question ça peut toucher
personne en beau le syndicat de
copropriété mais ensuite les travaux de
réparation selon la loi il en a
l'obligation a coûté environ 20000
dollars un phare tout réparer ça puis il
se tourne vers l'assureur du co
propriétaires pour qu'ils payent la note
mais suit un refus l'assureur se dit
qu'il n'est pas un devoir de rembourser
ceux ci et qu'il faut avant tout nous le
syndicat de copropriété démontrer qu'il
ya eu faute et le démontrer la faute de
la personne qui la fsa vaisselle ça
devient un petit peu difficile le
syndicat de copropriété ne peut pas être
indemnisé par son assureur puisque le
montant des dommages se situe sous sa
franchise qui est de 50 mille dollars
c'est donc le syndicat lui-même
c'est-à-dire l'ensemble des
copropriétaires qui doivent éponger la
facture
la modification d'un article du code
civil en 2018 a changé la façon dont les
compagnies d'assurance n'indemnisent
leurs clients en copropriété auparavant
les co propriétaires touchés par un
sinistre étaient des dommages est
presque automatiquement par leur
assureur même si le co propriétaire
n'était pas responsable
son assureur pouvait réparer chez lui
lorsqu'il avait des dommages chez lui
donc ça simplifié à l'époque la
résolution des plus petits si nice qui
était en deçà de la franchise du
syndicat parce que chaque copropriétaire
allait faire appel à son propre assureur
dorénavant tu dois prouver une faute ou
une responsabilité de mon assuré pour
que je te rembourse la franchise où le
montant des travaux les syndicats sont
rendus engagé des experts en sinistres
privés eux mêmes pour être en mesure de
faire leurs preuves donc des frais qui
s'accumulent selon l'avocate les
compagnies d'assurance se laisse
difficilement convaincre que leur
assurer une part de responsabilité
lorsque sinistre se déclare dans son
unité parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
c'est qu'au fur et à mesure c'était des
refus presque systématique des
assurances des copropriétaires c'est
faux d'affirmer que les assureurs
refusent systématiquement de payer
lorsqu'il ya des réclamations pour une
franchise dans le code d'un sinistre
selon le bureau d'assurance du canada
les dossiers litigieux ne représentent
qu'une minorité des réclamations les
assureurs s'acquittent de leurs
responsabilités un bain qu'on laisse
couler et qui déborde et qui causent des
dommages c'est assez simple de relier la
responsabilité à l'occupant des lieux et
à ce moment là
l'assureur payerait mais c'est pas
toujours évident de déterminer sa sas et
des cas simples mais il peut y avoir des
cas aussi qu'ils sont un peu plus
compliquées des cas plus compliqués
comme un lave vaisselle qui coule on a
un combo keita qui a acheté un nouveau
lave vaisselle lave vaisselle était
défectueux programme un enjeu de demain
au niveau du manufacturier mais
l'assureur du copropriétaire cas le lave
vaisselle est a fait défaut cause un
dégât d'eau nous a envoyé du côté du
syndicat vers le manufacturier du lave
vaisselle je pense aux copropriétaires
de poursuivre soit le fabricant ou
l'installateur et non pas aux syndicats
l'association québécoise des
gestionnaires de copropriété réclame des
changements à la loi pour faciliter la
démonstration de la faute d'un
copropriétaire
quant aux sinistres provient de son
unité on s'assure pour une situation
imprévisible pour avoir une paix
d'esprit lance moment ça cause beaucoup
plus
d'inconvénients aux gens en fête et de
stress parce qu'elles ne savent jamais
cela reste rare va payer non le ministre
des finances eric girard qui est
responsable du dossier se dit conscient
des problèmes il n'exclut pas de revoir
la loi on a un robinet de salle de bains
laissé ouvert on un débordement de
laveuses une chute de reins à thématiser
mais entre temps les sinistres
s'accumulent et les factures aussi qu'on
finit par éponger ni coup ni déficit est
tout chaud et puis on en est rendu à
plus de 5000 $ d'un autre côté avec les
nouvelles règles plusieurs syndicats de
copropriété on impression de s'être
transformé en compagnie d'assurance et
si olivier bastin radio canada montréal
[Musique]